[Music] Will we be able to maintain our 15th place in the Sissurai final? From here,
full throttle, at high speeds of up to 180 km/h, the
drone is slowly moving away.
To our viewers, we will deliver the tracking video of the drone from here. It will
no longer be possible. It has been installed in 5 locations.
Please enjoy the video from the camera The
thick waiting wall of Yota 86GT Bamboo moves forward,
blocking the entire body of car No. 86, slowing down the increase in car speed.The
invisible tribesmen are slowly
approaching, and the danger is coming.  The only thing that won't grow is to do your best. Hold on. The
margins you've earned through life-threatening climbs are being taken away because my car doesn't have the power. I can't help it. I'm
sorry for this. It's a
230km/h wall.
Most of the rivals of the No. 86 car god
clocked in at 300km/h here.At the
end of the straight, waiting for us was the Dongfeng Intersection.We plunged into a right-angled corner.
[Applause]
Despite losing our balance, we
cleared the corner.  Once you get through the gentle edge curves where you are pushing to the limit, the
home straight
finish is just around the corner.The
car in 16th place is closing in on you by 0.3 seconds.If you don't get passed by this guy, run away with all your might.Run
away with all your might.You're seriously on the edge of your seat.Where's the bump?  It would
be dangerous if the car that was coming was a powerful one, but there's no way
the car in this position
doesn't have power.
[Applause]
I'll finish later. [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Or
DET